liberalism was always going to unravel
this way
there's something within liberalism that
is intrinsically transgressive that is
intrinsically restless and is always
chafing at the bonds of conventions
whether it's social conventions or legal
conventions and so on and so you know
you imagine uh you know the liberal has
the sort of his son lit Uplands right
that's the Horizon towards which the
moral Arc of the universe as Obama
creates Martin Luther King is is always
tending and the trouble is that once the
liberalism hits it some lit Uplands uh
the liberal doesn't become a
conservative
you know the liberal doesn't say right
we've now got to conserve the sunlit
Uplands that that the the kind of
emancipatory dynamism of liberalism is
still there and so they might ask well
what about
the 1.2 percent of the population of the
sunlit Uplands that would prefer the
moonless happens
what about them eh what about their
rights okay well right uh well their
rights are Paramount right and we must
now reorganize the sunlight happens
to create a space that is respects the
moonlit uplanders and that means we
can't call the Upland the Sun National
moonlit anymore they're just lit
lit up so you get my you get my point
now what you're saying is progressives
value change in and of itself and they
will keep pursuing it even if they've
got to a really good point sure that's
what you're arguing that's what I'm
arguing and I don't think you know that
I think is a plausible take on the
dynamic of liberalism I should say by
the way that conservatives have the
opposite problem yes right so if if the
central question for liberals and
progressives is liberals metastasizing
into Progressive as I say organically
and naturally is where do we stop when
do we stop liberating when do we stop
progressing and say actually we've done
pretty well let's just try and settle
down and conserve these gains the
conservatives is saying well why why
change change what do you mean change
we've got to conserve this stuff no
absolutely not and so there's a sort of
Flip Side sort of dilemma of the
conservative which the conservatives
have always had which is well you know
the world changes our environment
changes culture changes Wars happen
one's got to adapt but it's not in the
conservative DNA to sort of accommodate
change and so both sides have these sort
of you know reverse but structurally
kind of complicit problems
foreign